[Musique]
tandiska 12 ans on connaissait à peine
nos tables de multiplication Elon Musk
lui avait déjà créé un jeu vidéo vendu
500 dollars
très vite il enchaîne ensuite les
projets fonds de Paypal SpaceX Tesla et
souhaite coloniser mars patrons atypique
Elon Musk aime aussi faire la fête et se
taper des barres avec un lance-flamme
son dernier coup avoir racheté Twitter
pour la modique somme de 44 milliards de
dollars et virer la plupart des
dirigeants de la plateforme
car avec Twitter Elon Musk a tout un
projet il souhaite une liberté
d'expression totale sur la plateforme
rendre les badges de certification
payant mettre en place un bouton de
correction monétiser les tweets
populaires et faire en sorte que Twitter
devienne en plus un service de
messagerie de paiement ou encore de VTC
ça fait beaucoup là non bref ces secrets
ces projets ses excès le milliardaire
Elon Musk bat-il dominer le monde
[Musique]
alors merci Fabrice d'être avec nous
merci d'être là vous êtes spécialiste
des réseaux sociaux
Elon Musk donc qui a racheté Twitter
c'est quoi ça va changer quoi ça va
changer potentiellement énormément de
choses la chose la plus visible
vraisemblablement ça sera la modération
ça il va y avoir des changements
probablement assez rapide et bien ça
l'autre chose visible assez rapidement
ça va être le fac checking ouais
visiblement il est deux et déjà en train
de mettre en place c'est un système
collaboratif communautaire pour le fake
et donc de passer à la présence
stratégique et de se reposer sur des
médias certifiés à quelque chose de plus
dynamique qui met
devoir payer alors c'est pas tout à fait
ça en fait ce qui va se passer c'est
qu'il y a une version Premium qui est
déjà en place aux États-Unis qui
comprend la certification de compte mais
tout un tas de fonctionnalités qui sont
réservées à des gens qui payent chaque
mois et ça va être disponible il
comprend en France donc ça veut dire que
moi je vais devoir payer ça veut dire
alors ça veut dire que vous et moi on va
devoir payer parce que pour l'instant on
est certifié mais demain on devra payer
certifié et avoir la version premium
mais que des gens n'ont jamais
vraiment que je vais payer 8 dollars
ça c'est comme c'est comme TF1 qui
veulent qu'on paye qui veulent qu'on
paye gratuit sur la TNT vous allez
pouvoir corriger votre tweet vous allez
avoir des tweets qui vont avoir encore
plus d'importance non non c'est ça 8
euros par mois tu te rends compte que ça
fait 8 euros ça fait 100 ça fait 100
balles par an personne
si transforme 1% de ses utilisateurs il
récupère dans les 200 millions de
dollars
vraiment les raisons de payer pour les
pauvres au final c'est pas si choquant
que ça Fabrice ça veut dire que si on
est riche à partir de 8 euros par mois
là on baisse franchement
que tu as payé la télé le truc mycanal
tu as payé ou je sais pas si tu as
d'autres abonnements Netflix
je ne paierai pas pour être certifié et
vous n'aurez plus la pastille mais vous
pouvez les enfants
donc vous c'est pour les gens qui
veulent avoir la
passionnel il va avoir tout un tas de
choses
typiquement des vidéos plus longues une
possibilité de filtrer parmi les
réponses à la mytho ça c'est comme quand
on dit franchement alors fabrique je
t'adore c'est c'est très simple tous les
gens qu'on teste là ont déjà pu
expérimenter cette approche de Delon
musk tous les jours conteste là
régulièrement ils prennent leur bagnole
ils ont une nouvelle fonctionnalité et
au final après la 25e fonctionnalité on
prend goût à ce genre de choses et on a
un rapport avec la Tesla qui est grosso
modo est celui d'un être humain normal
qu'un iPhone parce qu'en fait c'est ça
tu commences à avoir un truc on te dit
ouais tu vas voir un truc en plus dans
ta voiture et il va faire pareil avec
Twitter ça veut dire que tu vas avoir
des trucs en plus tu pourras tu pourras
faire plus de voix comme tu as dit des
vidéos plus longues et moi moi vous
charrier franchement je vais pas payer 8
euros par mois même pas dans les rêves
vous êtes pas obligé même pas dans les
rêves donc ils vont quoi ils enlèvent
[Rires]
c'est ta grand-mère je pense que ça va
quand même demandé quelques mois avant
d'être opérationnel en France quand ils
vont faire avec les gros compte comme ça
le patron Twitter France il y a trois
quatre gros cons comme ça qui disent on
paye pas qu'est-ce qu'ils font ah bah
c'est Damien qui c'est au patron Twitter
France qu'il faut poser la question
j'imagine qu'ils vont quand même en
offrir à certaines personnes typiquement
ça pourrait tout à fait
peut-être mais ils ont les moyens de
faire ça pour les 1000 plus gros compte
français ça va non non je pense qu'ils
vont nous offrir quelques uns après de
gens réticents j'ai vu que vous vous
n'étiez pas prêt à payer Jean-Michel
Apathie n'est pas prêt à payer il a
combien Jean-Michel beaucoup moins que
vous non mais ils font pas peut-être je
crois qu'ils vont prendre les gros cons
ils vont aller en rémunération ou en
falloir beaucoup moins que vous de toute
façon dans les deux cas de figure et au
calme-toi Fabrice
je t'aimais bien mais attention oui
Fabrice vous n'avez pas l'air choqué par
ça moi c'est ça
calmement mais ça veut dire quand même
que un service gratuit vous parlez de la
voiture la voiture on l'achète là on a
un Twitter gratuit tout le monde qui
sert d'information et la pastille
maintenant est payante moi je trouve ça
choquant ça dépend concrètement le
modèle économique des plateformes qui
est basé sur la publicité n'est pas
suffisant pour avoir une modération à la
hauteur c'est pas possible que soit
Facebook TikTok Twitter peu importe la
publicité n'est pas suffisante pour se
payer une modération il va falloir un
moment que certaines personnes payent ce
que propose Elon Musk c'est Clairis paie
que les riches paies pour que tout le
monde ait un service de modération dans
la piscine
de plus
voilà il y a qu'à un moment que 44 ou 45
ça va c'est comme une pointure tu la
prends quand même tu dis je vais mettre
une petite semelle partout le premier
gros coup de conne d'Elon musk pour
montrer qu'il essaie d'apport à tout le
monde c'est de rétablir le compte de
Kanye West qui a été suspendu à quelques
parce qu'il a posté des tweets
antisémites est-ce que c'est pas
dangereux c'est est-ce que ça veut pas
dire qu'on va laisser la porte ouverte
au tweet raciste homophobe antisémite
dangereux c'est un culturel le gap aux
États-Unis
aussi choquant que ça puisse paraître on
a parfaitement le droit de tenir des
propos antisémites et aussi étonnant que
ça puisse paraître le fait de censurer
quelqu'un pour avoir tenu des propos je
dis Sémites vont pas choquer énormément
de gens y compris des gens qui sont
eux-mêmes choqués par des propos
autistes même si ça évolue par les temps
qui courent en France c'est absolument
pas comme ça qu'on fonctionne et en
France un compte comme Kanye West sera
vraisemblablement censuré et pas
accessible de bien référence mais
accessible depuis l'étranger
c'est tout simplement le compte de Kanye
West en France même si nous on condamne
l'antisémitisme mais aux États-Unis si
vous condamnez un leader politique
étranger vous allez pas pour autant
vouloir le sens serait auprès de sa pop
population qu'il a élu donc très
concrètement
tient des propos qui selon la loi
française sont totalement interdits
théoriquement avec une modération à la
hauteur il ne devrait pas être
accessible en France dans ses propos sa
musique c'est autre chose mais dans ces
propos ces propos étant illégaux en
France ils devraient être illégaux et
censurés en France ils ne sont pas
nécessairement en Italie en Espagne en
Pologne on va pas faire deux heures là
en ce qui concerne les paiements le
paiement des petits certifiés moi ça me
choque absolument pas parce que en fait
depuis le début que ce soit Facebook
Twitter Instagram les gens qui ont le le
macaron se font de l'argent avec on est
influenceurs on se fait de l'argent sur
une plateforme c'est un service et moi
je trouve que c'est ça a été très beau
jusqu'à présent que ce soit gratuit donc
c'est tout à fait normal
où on peut se faire beaucoup d'argent
quand on a la pastille certifiée comme
ça les marques viennent vers nous on a
une légitimité donc je trouve ça tout à
fait normal qu'on rétribue enfin qu'on
paye je veux bien la recette parce que
j'ai une pastille bleue et je n'ai
jamais réussi à faire d'argent avec moi
non plus
les autres personnes qui ont macarons
certifié se font beaucoup d'argent avec
donc c'est tout à fait normal que ils
prennent ils prennent
ma gueule
j'ai fermé ma gueule oui j'aimerais
savoir beaucoup de gens pourquoi ils
rachète 44 milliards cette plateforme
quel est son intérêt fondamental
vraiment financier il est pas financier
il y a beaucoup beaucoup
c'est quelqu'un qui a je crois 230
milliards de fortune personnelle donc au
bout d'un moment si vous voulez vous
pouvez pas prendre d'autres jets privés
en même temps c'est un moment
donc il s'est fait plaisir il veut jouer
à un jeu qui qui finalement assez
courant dans les méga entreprises tech
de la Silicon Valley qui est celui de la
politique et il a un jeu qui est mis en
politique qui est géopolitique il a un
rôle majeur typiquement dans la guerre
en Ukraine mais pas que et il veut
affirmer ce rôle et commencer à
s'investir dans ce rôle là
alors ça paraît une somme gigantesque
pour vous et moi mais pour lui c'est
l'équivalent du maison de campagne c'est
pas non plus délirant quelle campagne
belle euh grande campagne
à ce rythme c'est presque un pays qui
peut s'acheter Béatrice alors moi
j'adore je soutiens absolument il va
démocratiser les pastilles qui sont un
snobisme les gens en fait c'était
accessible qu'à des gens qui faisaient
partie d'une espèce d'élite alors que là
ça n'enverra rien à personne par exemple
votre compte avec
votre compte il y a des millions
d'abonnés ça ne vous enlèvera rien vous
continuerez à tweeter comme avant les
gens s'abonneront à vous comme avant
rien ne changera si vous ne voulez pas
payer maintenant
je voudrais dire je voudrais juste dire
pour répondre à ce que tu disais sur
Kanye West il y a bien des talibans qui
ont Twitter il y a ça a été dans tous
les mecs j'en peux plus la Kanye West on
s'en
foutu
mais parce qu'en fait il a beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent il a tellement
d'argent que maintenant l'argent fou et
donc maintenant il va prendre Twitter et
comme ça il va pouvoir dominer le monde
d'un point de vue politique il va
influencer les démocraties les
consciences et ça je pense que c'est un
derrière vos écrans de fumée que vous
avez dû voir on sait que les fake news
aujourd'hui se propagent 7 fois plus
vite que les bonnes nouvelles et je
pense que c'est un danger public et que
il va faire beaucoup de torts à plein de
démocrates à neutralité justement sur
les réseaux qui étaient très orienté
plutôt à gauche et donc il va promouvoir
une neutralité en fait
vous avez toutes les deux raisons le
problème c'est d'où on voit le problème
typiquement la liberté d'expression
absolue en France est un problème aux
Etats-Unis non la base de la base c'est
devenu un problème
moi je suis d'accord avec vous sur les
44 milliards il y a peut-être mis à
faire ce qu'il oublie un détail
là-dedans c'est les gens et un réseau
sociaux en chasse un autre réseau social
un réseau social
un cheval un cheval des chevaux
[Rires]
et peut-être qu'il a oublié les gens
dans l'histoire parce que en fait on
s'en fout de trucs sur tik Tokyo en
Chine le Tik Tok c'est pas innocent
c'est vraiment l'arrivée de la Chine
dans un autre réseau qui arriverait à
notre réseau qui arrive qui serait
vraisemblable